yesterday President Trump met with Jack
Dorsey the CEO of Twitter yes he met
with the CEO of Twitter out of habit
Trump met with the CEO of Twitter at
3:00 a.m. while sitting on the toilet
[Music]
I'm making his toilet really low great
he had a super low toilet yeah yeah it
was a reason he met with him the reason
President Trump met with Jack Dorsey was
Trump wanted to know why he is losing
followers yeah that's the real reason
yeah yeah there was an awkward moment
when Twitter CEO said nobody likes you
this true we were talking about this
backstage even his supporters heart die
hard they don't really like it he's a
douche but I'll vote for him
speaking of tech I wanted to mention
this is kind of strange Tesla CEO Elon
Musk
you know who's just invented whatever
electric cars spaceships you name it
Tesla CEO Elon Musk announced he wants
to now invent a noiseless leaf blower
yeah that's a noiseless leaf blower yeah
then someone took must to a hardware
store and showed him a rake
[Applause]